elon musk is set to take control of
twitter it's one of the biggest tech
acquisitions of all time so what will it
mean for the future of this popular
platform and for freedom of speech this
is inside story
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the program
i'm laura kyle
free speech is the bedrock of a
functioning democracy and twitter is its
digital town square these are the words
of the world's richest man and now the
owner of that town square
elon musk sealed the deal for 44 billion
dollars twitter's board unanimously
agreed to sell to the man promising to
promote free speech and transparency but
the future of the company is not yet
clear twitter has been losing value over
the past year and musk is notorious for
trying to silence his critics the social
media takeover sparked this reaction
from the white house
what i can tell you as a general matter
no matter who owns or runs uh twitter uh
the president has long been concerned
about the power of large social media
platforms uh what they have that power
they have over our everyday lives has
long argued that tech platforms must be
held accountable for the harms they
cause he's been a strong supporter of
fundamental reforms to achieve that goal
including reforms to section 230
enacting anti-trust reforms requiring
more transparency and more and he's
encouraged
that there's bipartisan interest in
congress in terms of what hypothetical
policies might happen i'm just not going
to speak to that
well after the purchase elon musk
tweeted yes and said i want to make
twitter better than ever by enhancing
the product with new features making
algorithms open source to increase trust
defeating the spambots and
authenticating all humans twitter has
tremendous potential he said i look
forward to working with the company and
the community of users to unlock it
well the move has sparked plenty of
reaction both good and bad here's what
some people in new york had to say
i just don't think it would be good if
he had all that control
and just because he has a lot of money
doesn't give him all that power i think
he'll turn it for the better
how so
uh
giving people more
freedom of speech
maybe bringing my man trump back to
twitter i don't think that that one
person should have full control of the
platform i think the people should have
their own voice and be able to share how
they feel he wants to buy it or whatever
and make it a private company but it's
like you already got so much money you
already got so much stuff why are you
messing with twitter bro like i'm on
twitter all the time but it's like why
are you over here buying twitter like
stunting on this you know well even if
you don't have a twitter account it is
unlikely that you've not heard of it
it's been around for 16 years it's a
platform based in the us for
microblogging and social networking
services it's estimated to have more
than 436 million registered users who
post and interact using short messages
known as tweets these users are regular
people like you and me also celebrities
organizations and governments who use
twitter to reach millions of people
elon musk is an avid tweeter with an
audience of more than 80 million
followers himself
in 2020 twitter's annual revenue reached
3.72 billion us dollars it's a
relatively small amount compared to
other giants likes like facebook that
made more than 84 billion dollars that
same year
let's bring in our guests now and
joining us from london we have quinn
mchugh executive director at article 19.
from los angeles we have ramesh
trinivasan professor of information
studies at the university of california
and also from london charles arthur a
journalist specializing in technology
and social media a very warm welcome to
all of you quinn let's start with you
why has twitter accepted elon musk's
offer when just a few days ago the board
unanimously agreed not to let the
takeover go through
well i think maybe some of uh
people who are more inclined on the
business press can speak to that maybe
charles can speak to that relatively
well but it's clear that the offer that
was ultimately made um exceeded the
share price of twitter at the present
rate such that it was a very attractive
bid even after they the twitter board
had put in a poison pill notoriously
just last week on any kind of attempts
at takeover charles you agree with that
was this an offer that was simply too
good for twitter to refuse in the end
well it's interesting that twitter was
due to report its first quarter results
this thursday and it's not now going to
do this so
some people feel that with the general
slowdown in the world economy that maybe
things weren't looking so good and
actually this was the best offer
actually on the table it was easy for
them to refuse the offer initially
because musk didn't have the financing
then they were hoping that maybe someone
else might turn up and have more money
it's less than the share price was the
55 that musk is offering is less than
the share prices uh last year when it
was around about 80 but it's more than
it has been so
it's the sort of thing where it was the
best offer around and possibly they
didn't see things improving so yes it's
it's pretty obvious in that respect why
they took it okay take money you better
have the birdman
ramesh it is a lot of money for a
business that's been described as
woefully unprofitable
why did elon why is elon musk wanted
oh well first of all elon musk loves to
get into little you know battles and
turf wars and little you know sort of
arm wrestling matches on twitter he
really enjoys uh being active on twitter
and i also think that it fits within
elon musk's ideological portfolio if you
will right we see him owning multiple
other types of companies and he's always
kind of been this person who likes to be
a little bit outlandish in his sort of
claims for free speech and so now he
owns a social media wing to his media
conglomerate empire and so for him it's
a major achievement um and twitter
despite not necessarily being profitable
remains extremely influential especially
on media itself right reporters all
around the world often source and engage
with stories via twitter ramesh given
that twitter is so influential in
society is it right that such a powerful
tool should be in the hands of just one
man
i think it's extremely problematic
actually not for many many different
reasons um first of all twitter was
already encountering huge issues with
algorithmically powered disinformation
what i mean by that is content was being
targeted to people and going viral that
tended to be hateful conspiratorial and
really kind of grabbing of people's
attention so that's not the way any sort
of media network should function there
should be some baseline of kind of
commonality to what people see
it's really problematic even more so
because musk himself has boasted quite
widely that he's a free speech
absolutist right so what does that mean
that means in any given society
when we talk about free speech we should
have lots of different kinds of speech
be part of the platform but what we
found again and again on twitter and
musk is highly unlikely to do anything
about it is that hateful speech or
speech that is intended to grab your
attention is the content that ends up
going viral again and again so
uh musk who has been always against
regulation of almost any kind
and calls himself a free free speech
absolutist as a private you know wealthy
hyper wealthy person wealthiest person
in the world
this this recipe is a concoction for
even greater problems with big tax uh
takeover of all of our lives around the
world and i want to do everything we can
to sort of rein this in and balance the
playing fields a little bit more just as
a smaller side rummage why is that hate
speech so popular on people's news feeds
that's a great question so the reason
why is what is happening with all
technology platforms is data is
constantly back being gathered about
hundreds you know of the hundreds of
billions of people hundreds of millions
of people excuse me
all around the world so data around what
we look at how long we look at it what
we tweet what we comment on etc this is
all fine-grained behavioral data so
based on the data that's been captured
about us all the time without us really
even being aware of it content is being
suggested based on prediction all based
on correlation prediction of what will
capture our attention so the business
model of the technology platform is to
keep us all locked in there all the time
and one thing that gets all of our
attention no matter who we are is crazy
or outrageous content so unless that is
fundamentally intervened with and musk
has given no uh signals that that's
something he really ultimately cares
about which is an instrument of
democracy some baseline of common
understanding uh then our problems
continue but quinn how much could that
be countered by making the algorithms
open source exposing them so that people
have more control over what they see
because that is also something that musk
has said he wants to do
i think we need to be clear what we're
talking about when we talk about
algorithmic transparency which is
something our organization has called
for numerous other people have as well
there's the the transparency of what the
algorithm is itself
um but then there's also transparency in
terms of how it actually operates just
having the code out there doesn't
necessarily tell you about the little
tweets and various things that are going
on so one way of making companies more
accessible is making more of the code
out there for people to look at to
evaluate and otherwise but as ramesh was
saying the fundamental problem is the
attention economy and that is what
drives the business model of this
company and much more successful
companies than twitter if you look at
facebook and youtube and it's that the
fundamental business model that
centralizes control
over what we see and what we do and what
we interact with in a few small powerful
companies hands
so charles is what elon musk is wanting
to do with twitter is it realistic i
mean he's given very few details no
details on how he proposes to reduce
censorship we don't even know if he can
sort of expose this algorithm how would
that work is this something that he's
actually going to see happen
what he said has been quite
contradictory he's talked about things
like getting rid of bots but at the same
time
being a free speech absolutist but bots
are a form of free speech so where's the
line there similarly you know are you
going to allow terrorist videos are you
going to allow child sexual abuse
material obviously not um so your free
speech absolute absolutism clearly has a
line and the question is where does he
draw the line and
i i think that's the complicated part
that that you know it's very easy to
talk about these things at conferences
but actually when you're running the
company it becomes a different question
i think that the the point the remission
quina both made about the algorithm is
interesting actually
if you were to remove the algorithm that
amplifies content that amplifies outrage
which is the thing that we pay attention
to
then you'd have a sort of a stripped
back of twitter one which is much more
just about what people are saying rather
than things being thrust at you to gain
your interest because that's what gets
advertising in front of you and if
twitter doesn't necessarily have to
survive on advertising then it might be
able to take on a different sort of
character but he's given no clues about
that he's made fake noises about
subscriptions but if he was to change
the character of twitter that way that
that could actually have a big impact
both on this this information
and on the attention economy as quinn
described it but do you think people
will still want to use it i mean you
know as human beings we do tend to be
drawn towards this sort of dramatic
speech if that's not there if it doesn't
exist
what's the point in using it we want to
be entertained don't we essentially
personally i never see any twitter ads
and i don't get the algorithmic uh
twitter feed because i use a third-party
app called tweetbot and uh it only gets
the sort of chronological timeline and
no ads so in that sense i'm getting you
know the twitter that that uh it used to
be and most possibly it could be so you
know this is totally possible and i use
it all the time because i'm a journalist
and as from said you know journalists
are drawn to it because that's where you
find news really quickly where you find
sources you find information
quinn he has said that he would allow
the laws of each individual country to
govern the free speech or or predict or
determine what free speech is allowed
but how does that work when twitter is a
global entity and there are so many
different countries with so many
different laws
well i think you've zeroed in on
something that's going to be a
fundamental problem to the idea of um
really enforcing what we consider the
global international norms on freedom of
expression which is at presence time
according to our own research freedom of
expression globally is at its lowest
level in 20 years
and this is increasingly driven by laws
passed at the national level that
restrict
significantly and severely
what global media companies like twitter
facebook and others are allowed to do or
that gives company or gives governments
huge control over the kind of content
whether it's through data localization
laws requiring companies to hold data on
all of their users in a country within
the country whether it's things like
landing laws so for example requiring
companies to have local offices in
countries which then gives governments a
form of pressure and influence over
what's being done because staff can be
held hostage so the global picture
becomes much more complex when you take
into account the different laws and the
fact that actually democracy is at its
lowest ebb in 20 to 30 years that means
it's incredibly complex to find places
where that view of freedom of expression
is as supported as he may think it is
ramesh we we heard that from the white
house that biden is concerned about such
concentrations of power in social media
companies that was the extent that they
went to they didn't comment specifically
on this case but what can governments do
about it i mean how can they police this
sort of
takeover even if they wanted to
right and i think what we're headed to
potentially and very problematically
will be this false choice between a free
speech absolutist a private hyper
wealthy guy who basically kind of says
let let the wildfires uh go
and the backlash is going to be a
censorship kind of model by a lot of
restrictive and sort of authoritative
governments and states and and this is
going to end up being an a really
problematic flash point because the real
issue should be governing these
platforms not so not solely in their
private accumulative profit and
valuation-driven interest but in a
democratic interest right and so here in
the united states i have several
colleagues connected to the
administration and also people i work
with in congress and there's widespread
dissatisfaction with the status quo but
we have seen very little in terms of
actual action either taken by the
federal trade commission the federal
communications commission or on a
congressional level despite this
widespread kind of discontent and i
think the reason why is because the
biggest lobbyists um in democratic
administrations and to some extent in
republican administrations despite sort
of high profile you know flash points
like little controversies
are the big tech companies we should no
longer think about big technology
companies as simply social media or
simply technology companies uh they're
the wealthiest and most powerful
companies in the history of the world
when our military budget gets expanded
under the biden administration to record
levels many of those contracts go to
technology companies right so they've
taken over every aspect of our lives by
monetizing our attention by grabbing our
data and by basically taking our
anxieties and emotions as their raw
materials for a new expansive immersive
form of digital capitalism so we need to
think about what people need in their
actual interests right what a real free
speech looks like in balance with a free
media right we really need to think
about those issues so people can be
uplifted along with these companies as
well
charles how concerning do you find it
that all of that power that ramesh has
just been talking about at least in
twitter's uh concern is now in the hands
of one man
well i mean
social media in the form of facebook is
in effect in the hands of mark
zuckerberg google uh is effectively held
by uh sergey brin and larry page because
they have all the voting stocks so yeah
we're very much in a situation where
you have an incredible concentration of
power um and the u.s congress because of
course there are american companies
struggles to
find ways to regulate these companies
because it's not quite sure what it is
that it wants them to do or not do it
wants not to be bad but it doesn't know
quite how to do that without tripping
all over the first amendment which of
course stops the us government from
impeding what companies can say and
affect what citizens can say
there's possibly more movement on that
in europe because of the digital markets
act and the digital services act which
may have some sort of leverage over
these companies um but that remains to
be seen i think that'll start to become
a bit clearer in the next couple of
years but again the the question becomes
one of all if they if the companies
withdraw their services and they say
well we're not going to you know i'm not
going to show up in france germany italy
wherever
do the governments cave in because the
citizens demand the services or do other
services spring up it's difficult to say
and let's not forget of course that
governments use these services
themselves i mean governments use
twitter to release their policies i mean
let's not forget that trump was hugely
successful largely on the back of his
tweets we were reporting them all the
time at 3am here at al jazeera
what chance do you think
trump might get his account back
well i think
considering that elon musk himself has
talked about restoring the account i
think it's a fairly
significant likelihood and while i may
be living in britain right now i do
remember the
very problematic days of as you yourself
said recording constantly the tweets
coming from donald trump and at the very
moment when it's being found that there
was a significant
insurrection planned an attempt to
overthrow the u.s election orchestrated
by donald trump i think we need to take
seriously that that's a real risk
politically and for democracy in the
united states and not just be viewed at
a free speech lens one of the one of the
the powers of freedom of expression is
leveling between the powerful and the
powerless and one of the things that
we're concerned with because of elon
musk's own experiences is that he's
actually more concerned about ensuring
that those who are already powerful
don't find their voices constrained when
actually the attention should be placed
on those who are not in positions of
power and ensuring they're not driven
off platforms or that they have the same
kind of access as those who are
billionaires have
but if people do want to leave twitter
they can
do you think we will see a lot of people
leaving the platform quinn
it's very difficult to say um
one of the things i think we need to
take in into account is globally
twitter actually is not one of the
largest tech companies twitter has an
audience of about 430 440 million as you
said
um you know just taking into account
apps that are just strictly messenger
apps like whatsapp that has over 2
billion users telegram
a much smaller one has 550 million
we put a lot of emphasis on twitter
because it is really important for the
media and therefore content on twitter
gets amplified and crosses over into the
mainstream media a lot more
but
never leave the potential for innovation
um to decide i think charles mentions
that
maybe if these platforms are constrained
other services will jump up to take
their place
on a problematic side we've already seen
this happen in china where the large
western social media companies are
effectively banned or outright banned
and yet there's a very vibrant um yet
very censored social media
environment that's there so i do think
that if somehow twitter does disappear
or becomes a less
hospitable place for people to be that
there will be alternatives that arise
charles can musk walk this tightrope of
courting new leaders but also users but
also stopping defectors
well yeah many things are possible and
it has to be said that you know he he
has had successes
with uh building an electric vehicle
company at tesla
building reusable space rockets with
spacex and this is a this is a different
game because this is dealing with humans
and the very very
way that humans behave i mean it can be
done i mean we haven't mentioned the
financials of this yet which which are
tricky because he needs at least a
billion dollars a year to repay just the
interest on his debts twitter has never
come close to generating that sort of
money so
he's going to have to find some sort of
new business model for it really in
order to make it thrive and everyone
agrees that twitter has enormous value
but they can't quite see how to unlock
it advertising clearly isn't the way to
do it but you know if he was to make it
to sort of a backbone i'm also
communications backbone for the world
then you could see that there's uh
enormous value as you said you know to
to world leaders to people with huge
celebrity followings uh why would they
not want to
pay a certain amount of money in order
to be able to make their voices heard
and possibly that's a way forward so
that you can in effect you pay for your
free speech it might sound like a
contradiction but uh i'm sure that he'd
be fairly happy with that uh ibrahimovic
indeed he says he wants to unlock
twitter's tremendous potential what is
that potential do you think
well the potential is for it to be the
indisposable and indispensable tool for
us all to communicate with one another
you know much like what basically
facebook
meta's portfolio has really taken that
over so i think his real goal would be
to unlock twitter to be the absolute
tool that we use to connect with one
another and also just sort of learn
about the wider world the problem is is
the wider world as being presented to us
is not an open public sphere right in
any public sphere there are of course
going to be some hateful voices or some
people who are saying things that are
just not true the problem is is on
twitter much like on facebook which as
you all pointed out dominates sort of
the global south and the global kind of
marketplace on a lot of levels
especially if you include instagram and
whatsapp in their portfolio um the
problem is is that content the content
that they are fueling to us again and
again and again is the content designed
to grab our eyeballs so they're going to
have to explore different kinds of
business models that perhaps may be more
rooted in a certain kind of humanity
right in all of our voices and i do want
to make the point despite the potential
challenges in making the funds to pay
off this debt musk is the wealthiest
person in the history of the world he's
made a huge amount of wealth during the
pandemic as have all of the tech you
know billionaires approaching
trillionaires they've doubled their
wealth in many cases and reinstating the
former president on to twitter will be
an incredibly effective uh success in
terms of supporting musk's interests to
grow and build up the platform and have
it boom even more because the former
president was a central node on twitter
himself he was a central node because of
his messaging of often outrageous and
false content which went viral all the
time certainly some interesting times
ahead and we're gonna have to stay on
twitter to see what happens many thanks
for to you all for joining us today
quinn mchugh ramesh sridhara srivasan
and charles arthur
and thank you too for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website that's
aljazeera.com
and for further discussion do go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com aj
inside story and yes we are on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story from me
laura kyle and the whole team here in
doha it's goodbye for now
[Music]
you